vous voulez partir votre propre podcast
vous voulez à mener celui que vous avez
déjà un autre niveau
ça tombe bien on loue le studio sf ce
merveilleux studio dans lequel je suis
présentement et dans lequel également on
enregistre le sans filtre podcast parmi
tant d'autres la plupart du temps ce qui
empêche les gens de sauter dans
l'univers du podcast est en croissance
constante c'est le manque de
connaissances techniques et aussi le
manque de matériel d'un qu'à cela ne
tienne dans le studio sf on loue le
studio avec tout le matériel donc tous
les micros tous les caméras si vous
voulez faire une version vidéo de votre
podcast et ça vient aussi avec notre
technicien extraordinaire nicholl
nicholl qui va vous guider dans votre
projet c'est probablement la personne au
québec qui écoutent le plus de balados
indépendant parce qu'il y ait derrière
la console surtout les balados qu'on
enregistre au studio sf dont il va se
faire un plaisir de vous accompagner
dans ce processus là si vous voulez plus
d'information au sujet de la location du
studio écrivez nous à sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com
une production du studio sfr nous sans
filtre le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut avec nos invités dates ci
dessus perche quant à moi dôme plan
rouyère cette semaine le sans fil très
présenté par notre page
petrone notre page piquionne en fait
vous allez l'oeuvre abonnés ça coûte
trois pierres avaient accès à tous les
podcasts au moment qu'on les a filmés
donc en ce moment il ya plein de
podcasts exclusif qui sont là dessus on
fait aussi des podcasts exclusivement
pétrone 2 mais moi seule
on va refaire un prochainement justement
fait que si vous voulez allez avoir
accès à tous sur le lien il faut être
dans la description de la vidéo puis
c'est aussi un la meilleure façon de
nous encourager dans cette semaine cette
semaine on a reçu mathieu dufour soit
vous connaissez déjà bu vous le suivez
sur instagram puis vous capoter dessus
où ils vous connaissez pas encore c'est
juste une question de temps ces gars là
a un don littéralement un don je pense
pour parler pour raconter les anecdotes
pour être drôle
ce niveau reste
il va ses spectacles à une vitesse
absolument inimaginable il faut faire
les termes maisonneuve ce nom c'est
wilfrid pelletier
wilfrid pelletier qui est sold out from
hell place
il est vraiment il aura sur les réseaux
sociaux il fait des 108 ses incantations
ces deux rencontres à suivre le site
twitter vraiment drôle divertissant
illégaux ses saillies venu ici puis été
fidèle à lui même et il a été et est
drôle il est et il me racontait des
affaires puis on nous racontait aussi
comment qui s'est rendu le tout ça vient
c'est un lobby tous europe i phone ok
merci massue puis bon pas de gassiès
bonne écoute
[Musique]
ça lui même allo allo ota lui mais moi
ça va ça va bien on dit en entrevue
déjà je vais avoir une job vous avez des
patrons vous êtes comme entier pas fait
mon cv c'est quoi ta perdre ton pire
défaut pi 10 po je suis trop ambitieux
je suis perfectionné ça s'est passé sur
un bon atout à votre adresse et il faut
bien que supporte que tu prêt à porter
de notre entreprise
mais ma joie de vivre mon savoir faire
ça nous fait beaucoup mais j'ai
heureusement pas fait beaucoup d'entre
eux que j'en ai fait de lier une
situation j'en ai fait un très beau fait
beaucoup mais bien loin sinon j'en ai
pas fait beaucoup mais c'est tellement
j'arrive qui comme allauch ponctuelles
jeu puis le perd en plus le mot de mes
expériences les u14 entrevue pour des
jobs qui sait que la personne qui passe
en entrevue au maximum 50 plus que toi
mais il ya une espèce de jeu de pouvoir
vraiment chouette stylo la mer à tout et
je peux me sentir comme si j'étais la
pire merde parce que j'ai pas
d'expérience dans le domaine de la vente
mais troisième clé watch out je peux
fermer le magasin à la clé de la grille
le japon c'est ce qu'un vrai ça fait
longtemps que j'avais pas pensé à ces
histoires de
je pense qu'on les a dans le passé les
aimez mais sinon je travaille bien
équipé
mathieu suit
ça va pas être des enfants oui ça vaut
bien si lente et billets à un rythme que
j'en retire du jamais vu oui c'est un
peu de bon sens ouais mais même moi je
réalise pas ce que ça fait une couple de
fois que ça arrive puis mais à toutes
les fois c'est un peu fou puis je
réalise comme pat en fait c'est le le
premier le tlm prochains jours qui s'en
vient c'est à la salle wilfrid pelletier
trois mille classes 3000 places
incroyable c'est ça c'est comme fait un
peu et ce temps n'est pas de type o
games s'adressent tout le temps d comme
alors qui c'est quoi la prochaine étape
on a commencé avec des petites salles la
pression de fait le club soda on a fait
le capitole à québec puis on a décidé de
faire vous le ferez pelletier mettais
mon équipe m'a proposé ce qui était
commun ça pourrait être cette approche à
la fois petit globe mais j'arrête vous
de débiles ou quoi les gens
rationnellement m'ont pas laissé
personne fait un show le sol ou surtout
pas quand ça fait comme deux ennemis qui
étaient sortis de l'école nationale de
l'humour je veux dire c'est un peu fou
qui je fais tout le temps un peu de com
ok on embarque puis je me dis sauta le
pire qui va arriver au pays l'urgent dix
personnes dans celle bien jouer dans une
grosse al joura cachette de 1990 oui
j'en à la friperie mais dit il sont pas
s'arranger en avant le fait qu'il marque
le prix moins chers ils ont fait ça mais
ça va vite mais c'est fou les époux l'ex
tâche sur ma compta reconnaissant notre
ça mais c'est comme nouveau au site
effectivement autre côté je prends pour
hakim te tuer l'espèce de sentiments de
dire mettons un acquis non lolë c'est là
que que je suis dévoilé au public comme
est comme une fraude le team et ont à
chaque fois que tu grossis le truc de
fer qui n'ont laissé là je dois frapper
le
le bout est ce que le monde viendront
pas bloquer non mais là c'est l'appui ok
non pas encore
il le sait tout le temps c'était c'est
tout le temps parce que ce qui est
bizarre en fait c'est que de la manière
que j'ai fonctionné à faire des shows
puis à remplir les salles c'est que ça a
tout le temps été jusqu'à présent des
sages et là de la pire marée à dire sauf
prétentieux mais ça tout le temps était
désormais nécessaire exemple à un but
dans des temps records moi c'est ça mais
sur d'autres projets oui soldats
doucement c'est ça ouais c'est ça mais
ça tout le temps été soit fait que dans
le fond c'est ce qu'à chaque fois que
j'essaie de faire une réponse qui fait
sens mais maintenant je peux préciser ma
question est donc en gros si la place
d'études qui est le mettons dans ta tête
est ce que ton petit bois qui dit la
place d'avant le s'était plaint de
capacités puis ça grossit pas plus que
ceux non j'ai le goût quand même de
faire des avancées plus grosse mais en
fait ce qu'il faut juste pour que je me
mets de la pression c'est parce que ce
n'est pas normal ce que je vis il faut
pas que je me mets faut pas que ça soit
un standard de à chaque fois que
j'annonce une nouvelle affaire qui est
plus grosse que je me dise que ça va
être sold out remettons parce que je
vous ai dit je vais être déçu en france
et une fait que je me mets ça mais pour
vrais sites côtiers c'est quand même de
quoi qu'il faut qu'je dans la game
mental quand même bizarre le tic on a
annoncé où il fait partie habituellement
les gens non c'est un show puis je dire
sont chez eux outre ils font pas de
l'événement spécial cagnes annoncé la
mise en vente c'est juste moi qui ai les
billets sont en ventes solides en sept
mois triste il n'était là pour la
première fois juste pour rire jetait
dans la billetterie
tu es toute l'équipe la billetterie
taylor en temps réel on avait les
rapports de vente en temps réel parce
qu'il s'attendait à ce que ça soit
rapide
effectivement c'est sûr que ça ne mènera
pas une pression mais j'ai envie qu'on
me le 10 juin
j'ai comme un peu ça crée un précédent
de comme j'aime ça quand ça sera mis
rapidement mais c'est quoi que je me
rapporte très terre-à-terre je me dis si
pour essais post récente et je m'enlève
l'apprécions beaucoup avec mon équipe je
rationaliste et ça va aller comme ça va
livre c'est pas trés santé c'est mon but
quand j'annonce une salle c'est pas que
ça soit soldate plus rapidement possible
ses parents du commun
should be
[Rires]
il ya deux grave est que j'ai fait
l'école nationale de l'humour
pierre-yves redémarrer sa main boisvert
qui ont appelé à manier en fait un show
ensemble qui ont appelé sur sold-out les
gens achetaient pas de billets pas ce
qu'il pensait des soldats c'est une
bonne idée ça passe quand même temps
c'est chaud c'est le 18 juillet à quito
dans le fond tu fais quoi distiller dans
le sens qui est en plus très chauds sont
improvisés mais j'imagine que tu te
prépares plus un peu passé gros en même
temps en même temps pas de temps que ses
dents sont les seuls à faire la seule
différence avec ce show là c'est que vu
que ça va être vu c'est dans un contexte
plus gros le vu que ça fait parler
beaucoup et puis vu ses plus gros je
vais pas charger la manière que je vois
être sur scène c'est à dire que je veux
quand même improvisé jeu quand même y
aller seul fly100 préparation des
chevaux comme fable idée d'un match
commence à noter c'est quand je pense à
des anecdotes drôles qui me sont
arrivées dans le passé que j'ai jamais
compter sur scène mais j'ai comme un
feeling quand je pense à une anecdote de
hausse à votre marché où ça va pas
marcher maintenant il ya des anecdotes
que je repense aussi je parle avec des
amis ma famille plein il ya une anecdote
qui revient sur le sujet
drôle je n'ai jamais compté sur ça en
fait je notamment celle qui s'appelle
jean wilfrid sold out
pigeant j'écris des idées d'anecdotes
que ça me tente de compter dans ses six
a fait des nouvelles affaires que j'ai
jamais compter avec ce jeu notre métier
je veux plus travailler le l'ouverture
du show qui émettront la fermeture du
chaud au tessin va me permettre d'aller
dans une fois de plus des jeeps de quoi
de plus comme grandiose parce que ça va
être la plus grosse salle que je vais
avoir fait ta vie c'est comme un peu
jean temouchent chose importante à un
godet pas de superstition le métier je
me dis c'est une grosse salle c'est quoi
ce bug faut que le début fausse tp
aurait fait je veux mais a joué un peu
âgé déjà décidées dans ma tête je me la
joue un peu agents céline dion 100 belge
et ses tantes les jo sans nouvelle c'est
qu'on allait vendre à notre vie c'est
quand il ya le black au début puis que
genre il ya comme une soit une vidéo
d'ouverture ou gentil de quoi un peu de
build up d'énergie
jo était de faire jégou de face aux mets
à suivre mais je veux comme travailler
plus dans le conteneur mais le contenu
trop tard dj quoi craquer comme la foule
avant d'entrer
moi j'aimerais ça au diamant mais avant
toute chose parce que ça commençait
j'aime surtout quand les gens en mal à
faire qui est tout de suite ça soit
comme un peu ambiance et une faune
spectacle fait si je me craignent tout
temps des playlists de genre 2000 smash
hits des mois je pu être moi m'a
également tout ce qui a changé c'est
débile mais ouais c'est ça fait que je
veux m'amuser vraiment comment bien aux
commandes est différente et les gens
sont ya de quoi dans le fait que ce soit
soldate davance demain tout ni de quoi
dedans l'énergie des gens qui viennent
maintenant il ya de quoi tu vraiment le
fun parce que les gens sont comme aux
chiffres j'ai réussi à avoir des billets
gens les gens entre les gens ont acheté
leurs billets cette mode avancé avec les
gens révoltés je me fait écrire tout le
temps sur les réseaux sociaux de jt
manteau 18 juillet au monde y est gentil
pour la fête de ma soeur je ressors des
pierres taillées comme un mille deux
cent vingt jours avant son show ils se
sont fait avec l'application de fonds
décaissés savez qu'il ya de quoi dans
l'énergie que j'aime se jouer avec ça
les gens sont contents d'être là fait
que je veux comme kate iphone soit
m'aimera d'ailleurs je te rappelle
dessus on avait on a notre chaude
solaire 5
on a fait un show avec un ben c'est
peut-être dark side of the poor
on était juste des nageurs faisait de la
musique puis on avait commencé notre
show avec la toune de 2001 l'odyssée de
l'espace telle espèce de temps en temps
tout était noir pleut on est de train
gratuits
en fait assez juste comme figo le tfc
disponible sur youtube des vidéos et on
tente et les petites attendant c'est
vrai mais j'ai fait comme quand à côté
s'attendre
c'était beau et ça ce n'est que c'est
vraiment là le seul son qui opère un
site cette section mais portable you had
one job mais ça fait bizarre
j'adore aller bosser c'est mon show qui
bouge je regarde tu parlais sandell
après moult prentice est comme un
exemple mais en fait ouais c'est ça le
monde me pose des questions l'aja riquet
soiffards a pris sa part après mes
pauvres et wilfrid ça a été jean pour
tout de suite le contingent fameux volts
complice aux gens je vois pas d'issue un
build up de salengro s'appuie un nombre
de capacités le sait pour la suite j'ai
comme signer mais j'ai comme le goût
aussi de refaire des affaires un peu
plus intime le meilleur des trucs était
comme l'âge est annoncée en avril j'ai
annoncé comme catch au cachet pour me
préparer justement pour me préparer à
wilfrid pelletier parce que comment je
travaille comment je décide les
anecdotes que je fait et c'est vraiment
pas conventionnel sa maison en humour
c'est un humoriste qui veut monter un
show qui veulent présenter maintenant
pendant deux ans bien deux succès que si
tu vas voir ce show là pendant deux ans
dit tu vas pas au revoir c'est comme
annoncer que c'est attend qu'il sorte un
autre jour avant d'aller le voir mais
comment ça fonctionne c'est un peu
choqué c'est que les gens il ya des gens
qui sont venus me voir à mettons ça une
fois à l'honneur de voir que les fouets
ben ça tout le temps exactement
puis il ya des gens qui sont une bourse
à une fois dans dernières années mis à
des gens qui vont avec la première fois
qu'ils vont me voir où ils prennent des
fêtes exemple l'anecdote à mettre une
anecdote que je compte souvent
maintenant qui marche super bien que moi
j'aime côté météo tête des gens qui
l'ont entendu et mettons trop 80
dernières années
je leur contraire wilfried ça serait
différente les gens ça dérangerait pas
mais moi j'ai comme un souci d'âge et le
goût que les
1 comme de renouveau près de quoi de
différent fait que ce que j'ai décidé de
faire c'est que en avril je fais quatre
shows de 1h au terminal comedy club ça
va être quatre nouvelles heures total
d'enfants je me donne le défi de faire
rien de ce que j'ai déjà fait
sur scène et que je parraine fouillé
justement dans mes anecdotes
parlementaires et et de l'affrètement
son pari mais fake saison a fait que
j'ai annoncé céder 600 personnes la
capacité de cette salle là j'ai vraiment
hâte parce que je pense avec comme plus
c'est un team qui coule fait qu'après
vous l'offrir gens je veux pas annoncé
donc plus grosses salles pour tout de
suite doit attendre c'est sûr que ça va
venir
une autre pourrait oui c'est sûr ça va
venir c'est sûr je vais le faire parce
que juste pour le le trip de le faire je
sais c'est débile de se permettre de
faire de quoi de deux gros le pti pour
le très personnel ou si c'est fou de
jouer devant des foules de peu de bon
sens mais pour l'instant je veux pendant
cette fois de plus gros seins je vois
comme me reconcentrer pour faire des
affaires
un peu genre improvisé pitt et dede
concept un peu retourné aux sources et
non pas je suis rempli cette mode avant
ce stade le centre bell avec un promo
petit sud si vous réussir à vendre des
billets sans doute non mais je crains
qu'il ne manquait pas fait ça en vente
mais ouais mais s'ils mettent à raison
les sites mais sa tante polly
s'entendent pas l'oeuvre puis mais ça va
venir je pense à venir certains c'est
moi j'ai un regret qu'elle soit faire de
la visualisation puis un retrait dans le
conscient qu'ils jouent vraiment très
intéressant je trouve ça très cool puis
j'ai déjà une date à mon agenda qui
s'est écrite en berne au rouge est un
conte graphique gens ça va arriver c'est
sûr et certain jean paul rambert
mais je sais pas car des jeunes filles
en fait mais pour vous souhaiter des
cinq minutes à gauche à droite à
longueur de semaine où tu fais pas
vraiment ce nom c'est ça je fais pas de
jeu pas de soirées d'humour hockey parce
que betty d'enfants la soirée d'humour
qui s'est vraiment une méthode de
travail pour les humoristes qui écrivent
leurs textes ceux qui écrivent leurs
blagues c'est que ça leur permet d'aller
tester dans l'est comme essayer leurs
jobs devant comme plein de public mais
moi quand j'entends performance ou quand
je fais un show c'est vraiment ce que
j'aime c'est des fois tu comptais de
quoi pour la première fois peut-être un
peu dans le moment présent avec le
public fait d'aller faire un show en
plus cinq minutes c'est pas beaucoup
pour moi parce que je sais moi je fais
des anecdotes affecté jeu ça prend du
temps et des fois je peux commencer
terminant sur un show d'une âge que
faire 20 minutes de
parler de masse même parler de ma
journée puis après ça enclenchée sur des
affaires c'est plus que j'ai décidé de
faire cette soirée là était un cinq
minutes c'est un format qui meurent sans
- en fait c'est un format qui est plus
il faut qu'ils soient très condensée
qu'il soit et très punché deux comme
c'est à 5 minutes pour fait que je fais
pas vraiment ça je n'ai pas trouvé de
monter je me fais des fois écrire pour
aller danser telle ou telle soirée mais
je fais pas je fais pas vraiment ça
parce que sam ont récemment gouez
puisque d'autres choses parce que j'ai
pas aller tester des affaires fait c'est
quand j'y vois faut que choisissent de
quoi que j'ai déjà fait
c'est pas longtemps j'ai l'impression
d'être très dépêché ses comptes dès que
ça n'en fait pas toute une façon de
travailler qui est vraiment unique
puis je suis là je sais de la jemmerais
seul à comprendre en fait moi j'écrivais
des contes pour enfants qu'un voire une
couple d'années puis j'avais une
technique qui fonctionnait bien c'est à
dire que je partais avec avec juste une
idée globale puis j'avais un espèce de
chez moi dans ma tête qui se dessinait
qui me permettait d'écrire une histoire
somme toute assez rapidement toute façon
vraiment efficace
ouais et sculpte un genre de schéma 105
qu'ils soient nommés aussi clairement
que santa pas être de mettre en
situation initiale de merlin
l'enchanteur
est-ce que tu eu comme un espèce de chez
moi qui permet de vivre une histoire une
anecdote qui se passe dans ta vie de
dire à qui et comment maintenant est-ce
que peu parce que cette histoire là
cette anecdote la prise en tant que tel
peut s'articuler dans un contexte
humoristique
est-ce que tu as une espèce de chez moss
semble peut-être que tu l'as déjà nommé
mais quelque chose qui existe dans ta
tête qui comme qui est ce c'est comme ça
que je raconte une histoire pour que ce
soit drôle qu'est ce qui fait que ça
peut être drôle puisqu'ils figuraient de
l'extra ou quelque chose comme ça il
faut une bonne question c'est vraiment
une bonne question mais j'ai pas j'ai
pas de chez moi en tant que tel
comment je me comment met-on je me fis
pour savoir si c'est un anecdote si je
vous la conter aux silva c'est bizarre
mais ça c'est vraiment comme un feeling
si vraiment j'avais un feeling kg quand
je suis en train de vivre de quoi où
quand
je raconte une anecdote c'est vraiment
comme moi j'ai mon mon fil conducteur en
vie c'est comme si moi ça me fait rire
c'est un bon indicateur pour savoir si
jean jaurès compter sur cinq ou six ça
va être drôle
fake c'est pas mal ça en fait je le
compte vraiment c'est sûr ça une manière
de le compter c'est vraiment je recompte
jeu le synthétise pour aller à
l'essentiel était dans le sens que s'il
ya des gens qui ont pas cette capacité
là d'aller à l'essentiel en contre on
connaît tout du monde que quand même
temps il s'aligne sur une anecdote
et comme au sacre a marre on n'est pas
sorti si l'on avait des informations
importantes pour dire qu'ils avaient
aussi une autre personne que de le mée
exactement si ça c'est pas donné à tout
le monde mais ça mon envie c'est un de
mes forces de savoir jean c'est quoi les
éléments que j'ai acheté en ligne pour
les éléments pour qu'ils comprennent
qu'ils trouvent ça drôle je me suis vite
et on appelle ça des souffrances à des
référents outils embarqués le plus de
gens possible d'un images clairement
jeté un gros qui donne beaucoup d'image
si je donne beaucoup gens quand tu
écoutes me chope toutes les jambes
voyant non parce que c'est souvent je
veux vivre par des métaphores aux
bandits mais je pense souvent à sauter
un exemple qui me vient en tête herman
et gp3 l'école de limoges avec une joke
à main et pis j'avais dit je t'ai aller
patiner type mon ami georges frêche
expliqué j'entrerai en sportif change un
peu tout croche le puits j'avais juste
aller patiner projeter comme c'est mon
ami m'avait dit qu'elle le patin c'est
comme le vélo gentil ça se passera
trouvé refuge des comme ça se perd dans
les pattes j'avais dit j'avais l'air
d'un bébé hors niall qui essaient de se
tenir debout dans un champ peur c'était
seule image d'unité menant times est
mauvais ce que tu avais est ce que tu
avais pensé à cette image avant le
moment où est-ce qu'ils sortent de ta
bouche mais non c'est ça c'est comme
unis ça c'est nul c'est ce qu'il vient
la nasse mets sucrés mais vraiment
vraiment pour ce que demande son
communiqué ce qui sera fatale qu'est ce
qui se passe et textes souvent c'est
léger comme plein dimanche dans ma tête
j'ai une grande imagination
puis jeunes répartis quand même assez
forte c'est ce qui
c'est ça ma force david jeu ça me vient
rapidement j'ai fait beaucoup d'impro
j'aime ça même moi des fois je me
surprend c'est ce qui est drôle en fait
pourquoi j'improvise sur 5 pourquoi j'ai
pas de filet ou deux parce que ça
mettons à l'école de lemont j'écrivais
mes textes on n'avait pas le choix
giambi jamais sauf quand même faire
l'exercice j'écrivais mes textes mais on
dirait qu'une fois qu'ils étaient écrits
beloeil et figé compenser ça c'était ça
le l'image pouvait pas aller plus loin
la job pouvait pas aller plus loin
j'arrive et je le vivrais sortait sur
cinq qui c'était ce que j'avais pensé
jean deux jours avant le ton tandis que
quand j'ai produit sur scène
l'image fait dans ma taille pis il ya
des mots qui nous viennent en bouche
puis qu'ils sortent qui même moins
surpris un homme trompé j'ai dit ça pour
vous fait rire cinq étoiles j'en suis
actuellement dribble le généraliste que
j'ai dix objets comme un moyen d'entamer
gerima comprend fait c'est pour ça que
quand les gens viennent me voir en show
c'est très rare ont envie de quoi là
c'est une équipe qui se passe en ce
moment le pass cris des enfants que je
veux dire sur scène que c'est la
première fois que je dis que c'est la
dernière fois que je veux dire aussi
parce que ouais charge du tellement
marrant dans un show d'une heure et
demie que genre je prends même pas les
mots sont comme enregistrés note les
affaires pour de monter un show comme
mais non je trouve c'est ce qui fait la
beauté la marde gens il va sortir de ma
tête le tout le tacle à l'infini j'ai
déjà fait le test je peux parler des
quatre appuis
j'en sais pas ce qui manque ce réseau
cesame fait que gm se laisser sa
jeunesse à l'avenir le jeudi puis demain
je dirait l'autre chose c'est que c'est
vraiment ce que j'aime serez quitte
jamais non je me raconte pas mais désolé
mais c'est fascinant
- celle inverse de mettre le travail de
tous les humoristes ouest gifu ne fait
pas de radar d'un débat je me dirais que
paul mais c'est ça pis pour ceux que ça
à force d'en parler
1 si j'apprends aussi un peu à
comprendre comment je travaille c'est
parce que je ne savais pas énormément de
temps que je fais sur le sais je le show
à wilfrid-pelletier savoir être je pense
mon quinzième show avij tu es incroyable
fait que c'est quand même une ascension
qui a peu de bon sens mais m'engagerai
relativise puis
mais c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas qu
est-ce qu on parle cependant c'est pour
ça qu'il faut pour cela il faut pas que
j'essaie au début je comparais
énormément c'est en sortant de l'école
même pendant que j'étais à l'école je me
comparer tout est comme ok ça fonctionne
de même les gens fautif à 6h faut qu'il
y ait dans les bars faut que tu fasses
sauf ok faut qu'il y ait un 10 minutes
de bon après si on tient il on est 30
minutes puis l'occasion leurs trente
minutes de bon ça va prendre un amas
qu'ils refassent leur première heure
mais moi j'étais comme un vrai que j'ai
pas de gouges et jean françois longeot
ce fastidieux parce que les idées le
saviésan profusion dans ma tête le puis
je pourrais genre des gens avec du monde
pendant vraiment longtemps pris tout le
temps si j'aime sera votre fond de teint
gris qui traîne mais n'a en vitamine d
amis je me sens contes et des histoires
puis j'aime ce fait pour ce que le jeu
me compare plus maintenant si je me suis
même quand tu dis ces prêts à l'opposé
des humoristes comme un qui travaille
plus j'essaye pas d'en faire mon
entraîneur et que je sais pas que j'en
connaisse deux autres gaulois il n'est
pas comme les autres humoristes et c'est
pour ça que je voulais bonne mise et la
tutelle mais c'est juste que je dis
clairement comment mon travail puis
c'est demain que moi j'ai trouvé c'est
ma manière de fonctionner un gamin à
partir de maintenant je m'accroche
vraiment gestation puis pour vrai je me
regarde même côté je fais comme fidh
qu'est ce qui se fait depuis je sais pas
de nom mais ce que je fais j'essaye pas
de me comparer à quelqu'un tu mets ton
rodage mais dans la pratique c'est cosy
t'asseoir étaient amis ou de contes et
histoires 500 que ça soit ça soit
intellectualiser d'asseoir pratique nous
enfermer comportement bien amoureux
d'anna c'étaient des amis d'enfance
cécité qu'un socialiste doit justement
de temps tout le monde tout en compte
été d'enfer
oui c'est juste naturel pour tous avec
tahri sur sa maman c'est la mer c'est la
meilleure façon de pratiquer une machine
tu pratiques 24 heures est en train de
pratiquer vraiment eu sa chance quelques
anges compte t naturellement le
naturellement mon mental comme à café
permettant qu'on parle de quelque chose
si tu parles tu seras un lien mais ton
tu parles de chez pas trop mou du parler
de ton voyage dans le sud mais moi dans
ma tête j'ai plein de sites flash qui ne
viennent dans ma tête de caisse qui me
fait penser à un voyage dans le sud dans
ma tête on dit que moi dans ma vie
lorsque mon cerveau enregistre des
erreurs qui m'ont fait rire des affaires
qui sont drôles mec tu me rappellerai
pas de gens ce que j'ai mangé il
s'appelait à punta cana en 2000 2007
mais je me rappelais de la fois où j'en
étais pompe est un pub j'ai mon ami a
attiré sa brassière dans le buffet en
jeu
rappel ce pack en écoute je me rappelle
des avants de même fait que ça me pop
dance est justement fait premièrement ça
c'est la première affaire des fautes
avec des amis on parle plus il ya une
histoire qui compte c'est que je raconte
que les gens rient vraiment puis là je
me dis à cette histoire là c'est drôle
finalement jamais je n'ai jamais compté
sur scène
alors là je vole à noter que la note
dans ma note jean-louis triaud fait que
c'est une première manière de
fonctionner mais après ça la deuxième
manière de travailler mon envie c'est de
vivre au quotidien jean des anecdotes
mais bon ça dans ma vie a pas de bon
sens j'emmène tout petit j'aime ça
toutes mes journées vont s'aligner tout
le temps une phase niaiseuse ou une
phrase un peu en décalé quel montant
comme nous le voyons ça permette cecos a
visité avec de vivre des anecdotes qui
divisa faction pas de bon sens saf ont
dit que ces mêmes que je travaille en
petit de devenir obsédé par le fait de
vouloir vivre des affaires douteuses
matin puis bon qu'est-ce qu'est ce que
je fais de bizarre aujourd'hui
maintenant mais maintenant c'est de
tenter com - ge et comme je fais j'ai
quand même appris que je me savais tout
temps universal naturellement il faut
pas que je force
en fait si jal forces apparaît que ces
forces et c'est pas drôle c'est que j'ai
tout essayé de le faire ça marche pas
changé c'est que ça va arriver
naturellement il va arriver de quoi
genre comme puis que je veux voir la
petite affaire allait chercher là dedans
dit autant le savoir être dispo tout
supporter des situations un peu absurde
que je vais vivre qui vont s'engager
vers un anecdote que je comptais dix
minutes sur scène jean il ya un hôtel
qui savent à viry genre en taclant une
star bien sa gamme gens qui votent le 24
heures on ne reverra jamais mais comme
on va avoir ri parce que c'est celui ci
comme en deux groupes c'est naturel mais
pour échanger qu'un reflex à s'aiguiser
dans la vie pour voir comme à vaincre
issaoui au ballon ovale agences as fait
tu y es ce que est ce que
des fois tu vois du drôle dans quelque
chose qui est pas extraordinaire
c'est maintenant je comprends que
d'avoir un sens pour comprendre
qu'est-ce qui est dans une situation est
potentiellement drôle mais est-ce que
des fois juste dans le banal tu es
capable de faire ressurgir du drôle oui
je pense que oui je pense que c'est ça
marche je pense et c'est ma force en
fait lui-même dans dans des situations
qui sont tristes ou dans des stations
mais tant que personne rire est aux
personnes moi j'ai réussi le temps à
voir le jean d'angle de acceptant de
rire de tout on pratique
rires tu es souvent les gens se situe à
10 fois quelque chose de soi péjoratif
c'est quand tu ris de quelque chose de
méchant ou c'est pas bien meilleure
manière de tes rires sans émotion dans
vite c'est vrai c'est comme pleurer je
sais pas un espace aussi à quelque chose
de méchant ou de péjoratif c'est que je
pense que il ya une manière de rire de
tout invités puis il ya deux manières de
la porte est aussi métier exemple on
compare sur maintenant assez pour la
mort exemple la mort jeudi
seulement j'ai perdu un être cher
si ça peut être super triste mais moi
j'étais j'ai perdu mes grands parents
dans tt dans la dernière année genre à
deux mois d'intervalles dentist et les
personnes les plus proches de moi dans
ma vie je veux dire j'ai réussi quand
même à voir des aspects là dedans d'en
rire c'est d'en sortir
on les a faites en mairie mais dont il
ne sait pas s'il m'écoute qui sont
minces mais c'est toi qui choisis 30%
maintenant millions de l'époque les
drôles mais en même temps on les appelle
un fédérer pour neuf un gentil ça
s'appelle des reliquaires ne tue pas
vous rend si c'est pas un bijou ou même
stoppent j'écris avec un peu de chance
avec un peu de temps violent mettez moi
j'ai fait des petits comme des dix
pendentifs en petit jésus le chinois ou
pigistes un peu d'appétence mais si je
vais dans un show important mais je les
apporte à guam était dans mon cercle
bref j'ai très vite et ça m'arrive de
faire vidéocapsules dans ce genre faut
que j'oublie mon grand-père le comptoir
où es tu le lances à quelqu'un j'en
attrape ça m'arrive de faire des jo de
même qu'on présente le monde dit frank
lampard rythme lent c'est quoi j'ai mes
grands parents
comme brad faut que six échappés un
garde pas d'amour smoothie attend
pourtant comme manière de
je pense que jusqu'à va devoir de drôle
dans des placements j'en vois pas plus
de bien la porte et surtout hier j'ai
regardé historique tôt fait puis une
situation qui m'est arrivé je sais que
je peux pas les compter quand même à
l'infini je cuisine beaucoup d'envié
fait que beaucoup de pim arriveront le
cpie d'hinges pas un poivron sur quatre
et un mini poivrons puis j'ai jamais
j'ai coaché jeu j'avais pensé plus que
quelle est l'importance qu'ils
souhaitent puissent nous mettre d'accord
poste oui mais hier sur un poivron c'est
l'exemple parfait du rôle dans quelque
chose oui complètement normal tout va
pour avoir un bébé boit rwanda qui te
fait penser un soulier lutins bien
précis c'est de faire un montage d'un
lutin 100 pieds mais en prenant et de
poivrons pour faire ses pieds ah oui
route c'est pareil que moi je fonds
servent effectivement commencé c'est
exactement mon moi c'est ça mon réflexe
a été de faire tabarnak le cerveau dit
j'aimerais fonctionnent pas de la même
façon
ouais c'est comment est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui devient apparaître
comme ça tu es ce que parce que là je me
suis dit après ça j'ai pensé à ce puits
puis j'avais triche avec une épée ouais
je devais être le domaine le plus drôle
à l'école ce n'est pas l'école de
l'humour mais je voudrais à l'école joe
club mais c'est sûr que tout le monde
devait tout le temps attaque au t3 périr
le testeur ouest est resté sur mon
descriptif lots secondaires puis au
premier temps à toutes les fois de ma
vie c'est tout à fait sauter c'est le
plus drôle dans ton un album de
finissants
oui j'ai un fils à l'école secondaire
savais pas vraiment ce que je voulais
faire
je n'avais pas déjà même but précis j'en
savais que j'allais être dans la sphère
médiatique qui lâche une personnalité
publique parce que c'est ce que j'avais
envie de faire c'est autant ce qui m'a
allumé de faire rire les gens c'est de
mettre un sourire d'en face au monde le
que les gens disent elles ça fait du
bien et regardez ce que tu fais ça fait
du bien
avec moi ça pour vrai c'est vraiment
jean la plus grande reconnaissance
projets dans louis bernard roman j'adore
ça puis c'est tellement com est-ce que
c'est très valorisant sur cette très
cool puis je me dis c'est quand les gens
vivent quoi de tort que de quoi d'un
petit des passes difficiles depuis que
je reçois des messages pour me dire
était la seule personne qui réussit à
mettre un sourire j'ai quand même un bon
dieu dans la journée m je prends mon
temps pied au second dans ses sorties
j'ai relu toutes mes messages d'albums
dans le sens des gens pauvres et un
message jour genre en fait tous les
messages
ces éléments l'eau doit on va te revoir
à la télé on va te revoir et tu vas être
énumérées s'en va alors c'est sûr que tu
vas faire l'école nationale de l'humour
tout le monde écrivait ce gentil tout
fait tout le monde le voit depuis jean
tout le temps qu'ils m'offrent un peu
comme naïf là dedans puisque comme cool
cool et on verra ça va des petits je
sais pas tpiy l'école de l'humour je me
sens inscrits jean la veille de la date
limite des auditions py.g j'avais jamais
fait d'humour a vite et j'avais jamais
fait heures puis le mont options telles
vendredi planté jeudi
j'étais comme fort je regarde mon agenda
c'est comme si demain je pourchasse de
quoi se flageller pense à des enfants
j'ai écrit johnny n'a fait que très
grand pas ce que je fait six pieds capté
que j'écrivais des docks là dessus mais
tu es je pense et je fais de la fois
qu'ils me voulaient vraiment je les ai
faites temps que j'ai passé au deuxième
rang d'outil en tant que gérant très
première fois fait jeter comme la vie
marine c'est vrai que tout est battante
et achever leur [ __ ] en mode
s'improviser son audition belles d'antan
des quines offrir des taux qu'il faut
être dans - bellaing avons vu qu'il y
avait un contexte qui était quand même
sérieux c'était l'école nationale de
l'humour je voyais ça quand même gros un
peu jeté comme un j'ai suivi à la lettre
qu'est ce qu'ils voulaient que je fasse
c'est j'ai écrit un texte qui durait
environ cinq minutes des gmg fait le
texte
je m'étais écrit un texte et que j'ai
rangé suivi quand même mot pour mot qui
m'est avec certaines petites
d'improvisation sur le fly de c'est
parce que c'est un peu ma béquille
époque pas ma béquille mais gentil
remettant sur scène
sigean je suis dans un texte dit que
l'homme est rongé un blanc rouge en
double
quoi ces gens là au mode de survie sur
cinq de tomber en mode genre mauvais
attachez vous le faites pour ça que tu
essaies d'en monter deux options à
certaines plages en général j'ai fait de
commentaires aux gens j'ai accusé
certains d'affaires en improvisant mais
j'avais quand même un texte bien à
l'école mais tenter si vous demander
d'écrire des numéros chaque semaine mais
quand tu as réalisé acquis non moi c'est
vraiment l'un pro mon truc
ils te tuent comme encourage là dedans
qui choisit ou bande-annonce peu comme
ce qu'on fait ce bond reste je m'en
contente parce que je me savais pas quoi
puis de l'école de l'humour gens je
connaissais très au sérieux et et j'ai
je trouvais ça j'avais je me trouvais
comme chanceux de pouvoir suivre cette
formation là parce que c'est quand même
un rêve de petite fille autiste quand
même bien y goûter
moi j'ai une saguenay-lac-saint-jean une
loyauté de la latte et liste rouge et
vous voyez qui avaient fait l'école de
l'humour tu as comme auch i ppte et son
institution cb louise richer oh my god
fait que j'étais vraiment content d'être
là je m'étais dit je vais le vivre à 100
% et je veux vraiment su éviter j'étais
folle assidus choisis mes trucs fait
j'ai pas essayé de sortir du contexte de
décrire mes textes pour mimer vendredi
qu'on appelait les lient nos numéros
qu'on écrive à totti semaine puis c'est
comme vers la fin de ma deuxième année
que là à force d'écrire un texte tout
jeter comme un j'ai montré mes amis
parce que c'était filmé toutes nos
numéros on a tout autant qu'aux
d'ailleurs jean sursaut dans un futur
rapproché c'est terrible puis dans le
fossé savez je remonte à mes amis et mes
amis me faisais tout en un c'est drôle
mais c'est comme contre x et patois dans
ces drones mais c'est pas toi jean andré
qui comme on dit qu'un deux parcs nature
et éponyme
stéphanie dans un texte des classes ça
m'a vraiment genre ça me challenge il
l'a jamais vraiment trouvé
ouais je t'ai comme ok mais comment je
fais pour être moins de bord fait que
j'ai comme ça j'ai commencé vers la fin
de la deuxième année la maison on a une
rencontre avec un auteur à tout les
lundis matin puis je me suis demandée
jeter comme il faut que j'ai goûté avec
quoi de plus naturel le texte est pas
naturelle pis mon profil m'a encouragé à
remettons j'ai mon idée de numéros il me
dit enregistre war pas sur une ferme et
on parlera colloque par là des années
enregistré puis après ça écrit ce que tu
as enregistré puis ça a été la première
étape de
aller vers le plus triste est un montant
fixe était déjà mieux
j'en passe que par mois que je le
faisais je partais dans les buts je
partais dans les folies fait qu'ils
avaient des bonnes idées de santé de
l'offre condensé subts nous refaisons
web en joue et ça a été comme la
première piste de solution
puis après cela je lui racontais mais
comment ça s'est passé le lot j'ai
vraiment une gros déclic le sait que le
dernier vendredi qu'on présentait je
pense que dans un article dans le
journal de québec ou de mariage mais moi
si ça c'est que la veille de présenter
un show allait faire avec mes amis ou 2
83 puis la cessation des pompiers ça m'a
changé fait les auditions de 80 agents
fouillent et moi pourquoi me serais
remonté backstage est-il monté grogne où
il aime faire en été comme tout cas ça
consiste à coller aux auditions du 80
séquences à poil ultima c'est là que les
gens veulent que time où j'ai commis
aucune crise de schalke face au fait que
le finalement changé du tout anglais le
jeu des possibles avec les finalement le
pas le premier round c'est jugeant de
danger sur une tour m'est témoin je ne
souhaitais me fait que tu es comme
l'avaient inclus
[Rires]
ça fait quand son premier grand entre
les gens à danser sur scène y mettez moi
je faisais juste crié le monde dans le
bâti j'avais l'habitude sur scène avec
les autres golfeuses et l'audition était
vraiment pas à l'aise sur scène
effectivement j'ai comme moi ni mon
public en les faisant kribi parents
n'étant que hewitt sommes en effet que
de quatre heures
le flamand la deuxième ronde legault
dans les loges et nous dit le sa
deuxième ronde avec le ces votes c'est
votre moment de tout dévoiler mais ce
n'est sans façon c'est comme en ligne
jeux vers une carrière publique je
reçois merci mais non merci oui c'est
comme
oui mais non extrême il dit la forge
totalement appliqué il dit si jamais
vous là les juges en propre et une coupe
de minutes une cabine là pour ce genre
pour arriver un peu mais là moi je
vivais ça dans ma tête j'ai comme
anecdote année de contrat avec les
finalement installé sur la seine le
deuxième rang on dit rien montré jeudi
j'ai juste dans le sac un manche à balai
c'est super bon sur la nature des
importateurs sur les quais du monde mais
c'était ça fait que j'ai dansé là dessus
finalement j'ai comme garni c'est un
vote du public le monde criait on
vraiment crier en moi mais j'ai pas plus
grand ni finalement parce que j'avais
pas montrer mes graines d'artistes
étaient pas le tuer avec la c1 ou
gautier grandi mais je pensais que ça
serait cadeau de 50 pieds fait grève le
lendemain en arrivant à l'école j'ai
tout recraché ce que j'avais fait
gens que j'avais préparé comme texte que
j'ai compté sans mes amis bien sa
révélation le ton monte comme ben voyons
dans tes puis le monde est logé comprise
eu un déclic dans ma tête
or il faut que je compte mes affaires
qu'il tente qui me sont arrivées pour
vrai que j'en suis satisfait c'est à
partir de ce moment là j'ai commencé à
travailler mais pour le reste de ta vie
ton un point marquant dans ton parcours
va vous re était d'avoir fait d'avoir
dansé avec un balai ça prend une toute
autre tournure le vu que ça ferme
ouais c'est ce genre - je vais avoir
plus tragiques histoires de vie les gens
décideraient avoir parlé davantage que
le monde ça ils n en ont pas savoir ce
que le de 80 me demande qui vont savoir
donc savoir ce à la fois où tu aimes pas
gagné 50 d'arrêts de certaines maisons
sont commencés à j'imagine mais en fait
c'est ça j'ai tout tu l'avais sur la
capacité tulle a cette capacité là à
voir le connecter ouais puis moelleux
parce qu'on en a on caresse l'idée de
faire un jardin d'open maicon
on va le faire séparément mais on
caresse l'idée d'en faire éventuellement
weppes hypothèse puis moi je me disais
pour être capable de trouver une
anecdotes drôles et fallu que je
réfléchisse
ouais vraiment beaucoup le puis je
repasse mettons là ma tête
ok c'est quoi les c'est quoi les
histoires que je raconte mes amis les
histoires qui reviennent tout le temps
ouais sceptiques entre un groupe d'amis
le tu racontes tout le temps les mêmes
crises histoire et mettons tout le temps
les cinq mêmes personnes chaque fois
qu'une nouvelle personne n'a certes faut
qu'il entende cette anecdote le parti
trop du fait que je réfléchisse à ce
sujet fataki noms sur ces drôles fait
que là il a fallu que je réfléchisse
vraiment longtemps pour trouver une
affaire qui était potentiellement bol
pour pouvoir peut-être raconté dans un
cinq minutes
mais si j'imagine que ça peut aussi
passe à prendre mais s'entretenir lundi
la capacité d'un hiver à ceux restés
pour eux à une drôle oui mais ces gens
mangent artistes et que c'est comme un
musée on dit tant que la créativité et
puis là c'est un muscle que tu
entretiens puis à force de le fêter à
force de le faire tu es habitué
l'intissé comme dans n'importe quel
métier des atouts que tu développes
n'importe qui qui essayerait toujours la
même faire ce serait comme ben voyons
donc ça me demande toute la misère du
monde pour rien on est arrivé à un métro
ou du tiers de ce que toi tu penses mais
c'est là c'est la même affaire c'est que
c'est moi ça fait ça fait depuis le
début de ma ville que ça fait 25 ans que
je
fait rire le monde ça fait 25 ans que je
me s'offrir le monde que j'aime soir
raconter des histoires petit raconté des
anecdotes fake
honnêtement je pourrais des fois ça
marche des fois de comté de quoi
m'attendre et je fais des exercices dans
ma tête de près prendre n'importe quelle
histoire du genre en une seule c'est
drôle dans ce que j'aime c'est faire
sauter je trouve ça tout seul funky town
à faire aussi de son enfance social
aussi beaucoup le titre de garder
l'attention des gens de trouver les
méthodes de capter l'attention de faire
rire de rapporter si c'est comme très
humaine
j'aime ça aussi ça fait beaucoup
d'histoires gotti dribble sur les
relations sociales et j'adore ça me rend
très dense et rencontrer de nouvelles
personnes
une personne qui va ronger comprendre
les gens rapidement à tes devoirs dans
un groupe comme les gens agissent je
sois vraiment très cool je pense que
c'est directement en lien avec notamment
ceni ce réflexe là que j'existais depuis
25 ans sur ans fascinée par ce menti
aussi totalement instinctif naturel non
fondées ton style de trouver fait tôt me
trouvais justement kimouche bon là
dedans de manière vraiment naturel puis
je pense être dans 10 villages monstre
est géré par un cinq minutes le trait
d'humour pis c'est ce que je veux dire
il faut que je vous ai écouté tout liste
les listes pétrole du mot impossible on
prend des notes et qui est ce que je me
sois sur un poster de métier foule trop
intellectualiser 0 naturel tv 100% sûr
que je fasse un toit c'est un va tout
perdre sa demande et surtout dessus tout
une technique chez most common rail ou
juge conte des histoires opus naturelles
de même c'est fascinant mais
probablement probablement que
probablement qu'ils ont chez moi tu
prends ton cerveau capable de prendre
l'histoire la décortiquer de fer qui se
sait drôle commencions commença à
morphine will thomas banks et danton
inconsciente mais je pense que c'est
simplement que ce soit étudiée par
quelqu'un de la somme à quelqu'un
d'autre et que tout ça pour s après faut
être intéressant permettant à l'école on
avait plein cours sur
toutes les procédés humoristique qui
existe des dossiers la comparaison les
règles de 3 tc folle importance assez
folle intéressant puis je me rendais
compte que c'est je ne me force pas en
emmerdant mais numérotée je me force pas
à un inclure des trucs comme ça pour ça
sera plus drôle mais je me rends compte
qu'un écoutant mes anecdotes tout en
voyant ce que je raconte
naturellement c'est des trucs troisième
dans l'anecdotique qui viennent quand je
raconte des anecdotes parce que ça fait
partie de ce qui fait rire les gens et
qu'elles rendent comme naturellement
ladakh
on en parle souvent 2000 étudiants en
musique la littérature souvent on parle
de la théorie comme tel comme étant une
façon de sa tête pas décemment être
créatif mais ce que ça te permet de
faire c'est de comprendre si ça marche
pas pourquoi est-on toutes les théories
d'humour le tpr allemand qui a été
utilisé dans dans la façon avec laquelle
tu racontes des jo oui mais que si ça
fonctionne la façon avec laquelle je
raconte des histoires petit jack
on sent chris west et on s'en fout dans
le fond de la théorie le rire concernés
il ya un job qui lève pas puisque le pic
quelqu'un qui est la théorie pourrait
sûrement expliquer pourquoi ça lève toi
tu es au même titre que maintenant moi
en littérature si un texte qui est bon
on s'en fout de connaître la terre
humaine ont par contre s'il ya quelque
chose qui cloche d'avoir la théorie
permet de traquer le projet pilote ça
c'est vraiment intéressant c'est vrai
dans ce sens c'est la théorie
la théorie est né de l'analyse ce
qu'elle avait sur leur exacte de quelque
chose qui fonctionne et affecté je pense
que c'est ça c'est comme un cercle de je
crois qu'il faut pas d'avis essayer de
faire quelque chose qu'en se basant
complètement sorti de dons prendre tous
les a toutes les aspects théoriques pis
les rentrées dans quelque chose puisse
dire ça va fonctionner parce que c'est
la réussite il le succès vaut plus loin
qu'elle soit et je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de l'authenticité de
l'originalité derrière un travail ou en
oeuvre maintenant fait que je pense que
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est vrai
que la musique le jazz le ysk et parce
que des années 50 avec des gains qu'elle
est dingue
pis qui jouait de plus de notre possible
puis que je sais apprécier qu'on a
analysé ce colosse est enseignant
d'université
ouais pis il m'est souvent les meilleurs
musiciens tu vas voir les vraiment grand
théoricien c'était des bons ou très bons
musiciens
mais les meilleurs souvent cédé
instinctif qui il peut rapidement leurs
aidants membres qui joue pis qui on
osera d'urgence le pc les autres autour
justement qui canalise exédé comprendre
à chaque fois qu'il est justement si on
dirait que je parle de sopi je me vois
parler de tout et j'ai pas l'impression
que ta rennes parler de moi mais
justement tu es à force justement tu es
dans les dernières années il se lâche la
dernière année les derniers mois c'est
le cas aux yeux comme un plus gros seins
plus gros boum août et un plus gros
comme une attention portée mais parce
que j'ai faite de quoi de gros c'est
maintenant où il répété cette écoute qui
sortait de l'ordinaire
les gens qui comme qui roule pourquoi
pourquoi jean ça ça arrive mais ton
affection dès que à chaque fois qu'ils
arrivent un nouveau modèle ou quelque
chose de nouveau ça commence autant pas
justement de l'incompréhension ou de là
j'ai pas essayé de même de quoi de ce
système à tirants une société cédée
d'étiquette sur les choses qui ont très
souvent ça c'est moi j'étais fois
confrontés maintenant quand j'ai
commencé mes enfants c'est quand j'ai
commencé justement avoir plus de
visibilité sur les réseaux sociaux
bt mois au début je me fais éclater si
ça m'a pris du temps avant de commencer
mes dirigeants un humoriste je le dis
souvent le même thème au début le jeu
fait je fais pas de barre je fais pas du
tout dans les bars fait que les gens qui
font défaut dans les bars me croisent
pour me connaissent pas et pour le
milieu l'examen cependant ce milieu loge
grave est un peu ailleurs
et puis j'ai des amis là-bas mais je
fais pas ça et que les gens qui caresse
le rêve de devenir humoriste qui veulent
face à 100% qu'ils font sur de leur vie
de manière plus traditionnelle qui est
pas mauvais dans le sens que c'est une
manière de travailler puis je dire si sa
toile à toi c'est vraiment parfait mais
moi j'ai décidé d'aller ailleurs fait
que lis-je en mettant le voyez pas payé
par rapport à chez pas moment mon nombre
d'abonnés est ailleurs d'être rapidement
le monte comme qui me lisent pas un
humoriste
un influent créateurs de contenu ce goal
été faite le rapidement on dit je pense
que c'est ça la presse beaucoup la
comble à la conscience des gens mais ton
qui pourrait être offusqué ou genre
jaloux mettons rapidement de dire ok
ce n'est pas la compétition commence
c'est exactement ça passe tant créateurs
de contenu qui rend plus oui cette perte
il exactement
si ça permet de vous coûter des
créateurs complexe henri iv d'affaires
ça peut permettre de bien de lui mais je
pense que ça fait mais si ça a été
beaucoup souhaitent comprendre ça je
vais vu aller puis comme je vous ai
tantôt j'aime se comprendre les
comportements et même je me suis comme
analyser tout ça puis même mois le chu
reçues souvent confrontés à sauter au
début que j'ai beaucoup travaillé là
dessus mais c'est la comparaison je vous
disais le texas à l'école je regardais
des gens jeter comme au mont dieu puisse
tomber rapidement dans le hockey mais
non lutter comme trouver une raison pour
laquelle réussi puis une raison qui
pourtant maïs juste pour toi te garder
la conscience tranquille
mais nous au moment où j'ai passé
par-dessus ce puits de juste accepter le
succès de tout le monde est juste tombé
dans la la la si green business de jans
être content pour les gens réellement
c'est à partir de ce moment là quand tu
es capable de faire ce puits de juste
avoir une instit des attitudes de d'être
contact de dette reprenant la
comparaison paille dans lego points
devant rien moi c'est là que pour vrai
j'ai vu le gros changement dans ma vie
deux hôtes y ait toute l'énergie qui me
tais agente à comparer puis agent rage
et compte à personne qui avait géré en
2000 abonnés plus que toile des genres
mais le danger doit être remis ce genre
à avoir assez entendu cependant vite
entouré des bonnes personnes
ça ça fait là toute la différence à la
démarche ouais puis un versement de côté
les autres humoristes je peux créer la
bisbille mais est ce que tu sais encore
mettons juger ou mais les corps ou comme
si ta technique était pas le jeet sans
tuer inclus dans le milieu où pat encore
mais en même temps non je perce une
question d une question de perception
puis à qui tu vas te donner à qui tu
veux donner ton attention enfin bon
c'est sûr que des gens il va tout le
temps d'avoir des gens qui vont pas être
d'accord avec ce que je fais déjà qu'ils
qui vont gpo juger ou peu importe mais
ces gens là je ne les voit jamais je ne
fais pas je fais fi de tout ce qu'ils
pensent
c'est pourquoi je m'entends vraiment de
gens avec qui j'étais je travaille bien
et puis avec des gens qui sont comme
j'ai pas élevé de nos manières de faire
de deux concerts qui sont juste positif
qu'il fait pour vrai je lis plus ce
feeling je me suis tellement détacher de
ça que j'ai vraiment aucun problème
feeling d'imposteurs n ont aucunement
puis ce feeling d'imposteurs la haye et
créé par des personnes qui vont juger ou
par des personnes qui vont faire des
commentaires à météomédia tifa ton égard
mais si tu te rapporte à la base de
pourquoi ces gens là font ces
commentaires la salle est tout le temps
d'un problème d'ego problèmes d'orgueil
pas un problème de jalousie les gens
c'est pas mon problème
pour vrai moi moi en fait que eux
pensent d'eux mêmes mots ça m'empêche
d'avancer un soulagement tour des gens
qui sont faux king positif dans un bon
mode maintenant les que pour vrai ça a
été un problème dans deux mois n'aura
jamais vraiment content retourne on se
donne deux mois c'est pas mal on l'a
avancé de m'engager mais c'est tout
comprendre d'où ça vient
ce talent là parce que je me suis
développé jeunes malinké titre d'avoir
des jeux 10 ans puis à être drôle
ouais mais tu penses tu qu une raison
qui explique que c'est juste si city inn
et où ça s'est fait tout notre avis
mettons maintenant que tu es à force
d'avoir lu des livres là dessus à fortis
j'aime ce livre en affaires dans le
développement puis d'en être le lien
qu'on pourrait faire à celle récépissé
c'est vraiment intéressant j'avais on a
eu un cours sur à l'école nationale de
l'humour surtout de l'anthropologie du
rire d'eux pendant en argent aux
primates puis genre comment le rire est
comme dans une communauté tout dans une
société comment leur est pourquoi le
rire vient cpie des large dès le plus
jeune âge pourquoi tu ribéry puis ça
pour l'instant ce que je dis mais c'est
tellement intéressant cinquième mikko
préféré à l'école de l'humour
puis c'est le récit très pour
l'acceptation sociale de citer dans une
gaine fait rire le monde mais on dirait
que cela enlève toutes les autres si je
deviens comme accepter c'était cas pas
de faire rire était peu importe parmi
les classes sociales parmi bref faites
sûrement que peut-être ça a été un
d'acceptation qu'acheter jeunes de comme
faire rire le monde pour avoir comme
tels que ses aînés le tueur dit mais je
sais pas si je vous dirai pas le doigt
et mr absolument sûr mais aussi sûrement
que instinctivement ça a été ça en est
peut-être temps parle de foi qui était
pas delà de ce mouton secondes
ouais ouais ça sera pas où ça parlera
pas même temps que ça rapporte jeudi un
système des commandes enfants belges
tels énoncés
non non mais la puberté bien fait on
travaille dans ce sens qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui étaient tous vivants après
pts et comme times
c'est quand j'étais jeune je dis je me
compare souvent un ballon qui me parle
le jardin tout petit pays un peu gros le
pig la salle les gens omnicane pu
décoller mais non mais c'est ça mais
peut-être que c'est certain ça mais ça
surement rapport à ça pour vrai et si
c'était drôle fait que j'ai vu d'autres
ça m'étonne qu'on parle comme si on
était des animaux qui chante on est des
animaux mais remettons se mêle à même le
même mathieu un peu les gens qui
auraient été un peu jean ii du bac et
qui avait pas confiance je mets deux
mêmes personnes des gens tu prends moi
mettons qui était drôle tu faisais jade
et joy puisque tout le monde trouvait
drôle dit bref en plus prend l'eau d'à
côté qui lui fait possible sur mon
parcours était plus facile parce que je
me suis juste vraiment autant surfer sur
une vague de popularité mais de
commerçants pour ça fait que ça a été
vraiment plus facile je pense de passat
ravages de match et toutes les étapes
charnières l'eau de vie du secondaire
que ça va être difficile cité comme un
peu différents mais tombent mais type je
suis vraiment dans un petit pourcentage
jeter peu différent mais c'est sûr que
ça le 6 août samedi matin dans la mare
tic qui elle visait aussi que kate avait
fait prêter fait que l'entrevue que tu
avais fait d'un journal tu disais
quelque chose que j'aimerais qu'on
approfondisse un petit peu plus qui
était de ne pas vouloir te lancer dans
un million lafore way en même temps
maintenant les humoristes quand ça
explose maintenant des voix partout
ouais temps il est partout sur tout les
plateaux sur toutes les émissions peas a
fini pu l'indicé qui souhaiterait
sûrement eu les deux sont eux des offres
pour que ça fasse il doit sûrement eu
des du monde qui le voulait sur place en
août un outil peut parler
ouais ben en fait ça on approfondit ça
c'est quoi que moi je trouve qu'il fait
partie prenante de ma vie ma vision de
ma carrière
s'envole à l'ondé à long terme on prend
on annonçait d'esprit très attaché
nicole est super ok on décolle non mais
c'est quoi qui est tellement important
c'est que dans vie je suis pas pressé
jean je suis pas pressé par rapport à ma
carrière
par rapport à où est ce que mon côté de
vie professionnelle s'en va dans le sens
où je veux faire ce métier là depuis je
suis vraiment jeune
j'ai tout le temps si j'allais faire ce
métier là j'ai tout le temps su que ça
allait bien fonctionné c'est la seule
fois que je voulais faire pis j'ai tenu
un groupe positif par rapport à ceux
affichés comme je sais que geoff hurst
puis j'ai beaucoup douté mettons une de
mes idoles mais c'est ellen degeneres
puis c est l'un d'entre eux mal je dire
c'est quand même goal carrière
particulièrement parlant de ces gens un
apogée seller rendu vraiment un étape
jean autres biens à le 60 ans les crs
après un certain temps elle a 60 ans
élève dans une femme piquée à 60 ans
d'un petit pic à 25 puis mais exactement
ce soit fait pour vraiment envie changer
tout le temps dit que mon pic de
carrière le camp doit être rendue où je
veux à 100% que je vais avoir les
assises puis la confiance pour phase de
jeu puis les contacts et de l'expérience
je vais peut-être avoir j'en ai 45 50
ans 55 ans comprend avec moi j'ai cette
mentalité là que j'ai cette vision là
que je cours pas après quoi je cours pas
après un une réussite instantanée chargé
pour le goût d'être un foot pas les gens
de garrocher partout maintenant c'est à
d'urgents deux ans piégées
j'ai comme pas cette peur de manquer
quelque chose puis je pense que cette
parlait beaucoup
un clip quand tu parles de ce milieu lot
et tout le monde discute en france deux
instituts manque le bateau ils
repenseront tâche en salles arrive une
fois ouais mais tout le monde dit cette
phrase oh pis ça vient de quelque chose
c'est vrai que ça il ya quand même cette
nuance la de fautif a des bons choix
puis mais je pense que cette phrase d'un
mois seulement à lui mais en dedans de
moi c'est que le bateau il passe une
fois mais jean est longue croisière
j'en veux un grand projet un speedboat
et si le qui passe puis que si tu le
manges jeantet plus aucune chance de
réussir
moi je pense que le bateau justement y
est en train de passer y commence à
parler depuis gens que je coule depuis
cinq ans maintenant
puis le but de se re la raison pour
laquelle j'ai pour le goût d'un garage
nulle part c'est que choisit que des
affaires c'est qu'ils me qui me
ressemble
qui aime tant d'affaires qui colle avec
ce que ce que j'ai envie de profiter
comme image puis avec ce que je veux
faire
puis vu que j'ai pas là la peur
justement pis la presse de la truite
chose mais je veux pas m'engager mettons
dans un projet que je regardais les
résultats peuvent être comme au site
amorçant poppy le monde vont avoir connu
maintenant avec sopi c'est pas moi
maintenant je pense que c'est sûrement
la seule à faire là la seule clé c'est
tout le temps que c'était les affaires
qui ne tente puis c'est correct de voir
des humoristes et mettons qui commence à
m tiens exploser ou à réussir de les
voir beaucoup si je me fais déjà je me
fais je commence déjà à me faire dire
sur moi c'est des parm au pied pour des
gens du milieu où jean mon entourage de
tif attention faut pas de voir partout
faut préparer ouais il ya des gens qui
me disent ah mais moi dans ma tête j'ai
tellement la conscience viennent par
rapport à ça parce que sinon tu connais
pas le nom exactement pis dans ce sens
que c'est oui j'ai plein de projets qui
s'en viennent que des projets fous
l'extinction vraiment content mais en ce
moment dans ma vie je dis non à 90% des
affaires que je me fais proposer son
bras fait que j'en remercie déjà dit oui
de venir ici oui mais si ça fait dans ce
sens que je pourrais faire plus de
projet puis j'aime si j si je me fais
proposer que des affaires que j'aime
mais georges vote autant dire oui à des
affaires que j'aime les affaires que
j'ai le feeling est tentant de faire
parce que au final le résultat ça va
ressembler puis je veux pas mettre
dénaturer pour avoir de la tension
non c'est ça je pense l'importance et du
jour au lendemain quand peur de manquer
le bateau justement puisque tu commences
à sauter sur n'importe quel projet
n'existe project 10,1 gens pourquoi il a
fait sur jean boucault effet si je ne
sais pas mais ce que j'aurai des
exemples mais j'ai pas d'examen donné
mais c'est ce genre de jeu pourrait me
faire proposer le domaine d'être dans un
show est d'aller ainsi presque parfait
ali hatam aguemoune excité de come to
heaven intervention de commun faut que
je me fasse voir parce que j'en sais
important puis gentil mais ça arrive
tard et par rapport aux arrêts par
rapport avec ces temps-ci ce que je
traîne build up et maintenant je pense
qu'il faut voir ça à long terme beaucoup
tes parce que on n'est pas prêt à
essayer ça va bien aller puis gentil
j'y vais pour rester les gens ça me
tente puis je veux faire ça fait c'est
ça mon affaire de pots sauter sur tout
vraiment capacité de rester ici pas
grandie zen malgré le grand succès qui
étudie en ce moment c'est une vendre
vendre des choses comme ça à 12h sodat
il y en a un autre qui sera la remontée
attendent maintenant je pense que oui
mais oui probablement mais justement
j'ai comme l'impression que je me
considère chanceux d'avoir cette vision
là de ce métier là puis c'est très vrai
georges tellement tout le temps dans
l'authenticité puis tout le temps dans
le tout ce que je vous dis à ce moment
là je pourrais leur dire 25 mille fois
dans 25 mais l'entrevue de fait rentrer
totalement faux en ce moment j'ai pas
entraîne l'impression de devenir vendre
mathieu dufour pin de donner au public
ce qu'ils veulent entendre de jouer un
jeu 6-0 le genre 00 00 je dis juste que
je ma mentalité puis comment je pense
puis en ce moment c'est fou le change
mais je suis tellement reconnaissant de
tout qui arrive les gens c'est débile ce
genre pions wilfrid pelletier gens c'est
cool quand les rapports le même moi je
réalise paul déjean les clubs sur deux
utilise affaires soldate rapidement même
- le juge comme juif las vegas et part
seul mais ça vient je pense que sa part
ground zero ça vient de la raison pour
laquelle je fais ce que ça fait de
manière ça va ça vient de manière
comment je le fais du rapport
d'authenticité puis j'enchaîne juste moi
même puis comme je pense que les jeunes
femmes sophie gens je force personne à
me suivre puis gens gentils tout en
intégrant je le dis souvent je comment
pourrais je fais pas une souris la tuera
soir gens savent qu'on peut te
désabonnez vous je m'entoure je suis pas
dans le jeu aux sponsors set jo club
pour avoir pauvres gens vraiment pas ça
était gros ça monte rapidement en un an
ça a été un boom mais je reste la même
personne en arrêt de tous appuyé sur les
cartes de la même manière tige
j'agis complètement parer à ce que
j'agissais quand j'avais quatre mille
abonnés censurent snapshot en 2015
c'est la même mais même à faire mais je
pense que c'est sûrement mon moteur puis
c'est ce qui me permet de rester
jean terre-à-terre c'est il ya un espèce
de
le plus abordé un petit peu l'espèce de
sentiment de devoir tout faire
extrêmement rapidement espèce de
pression de performance lucky
omniprésente dans tout ce qu'on consomme
le trouves ton instagram c'est juste la
performance oui sur la performance
physique ou mentale puis effectivement
une question à se poser autour d'études
une question à se poser autour de
quesques jusqu'où tu es prêt à aller
pour la performance puis pour le succès
qu'est ce que ça représente vraiment
c'est quoi le moteur derrière tout ça et
puis le fait mais ton de dire que tu
pourrais pour possiblement remplir le
centre bell télé relativement
prochainement situe un succès du titre
le voit la fin c'est coup tu sais quoi
après le sait c'est que c'est quoi la
haine gold ans à succès où c'est le banc
parce qu'une fois que remplissant belle
a ajouté à précieux etc les plaines
d'abraham mais après sur ses côtés de
feu le top rapidement quand nous mettons
le bonheur que tu tires ou la
satisfaction ou mais comme le sentiment
du devoir accompli
si tu le retires d'un événement ou d'un
hâtives même que tu te même temps c'est
le citons bonheur dans la vie est relié
mettons à jour est heureux quand je vois
avoir fait ça si je pense est la pire
manière de fonctionner c'est la pire
manière de te créer un vide après
justement cette cette étape le parce que
ceci est maintenant je mettais mil davie
l'autize jamais partie ma carrière je
m'étais dit un mot le mongole gens c'est
de remplir wilfrid pelletier mettons
méjean jamais à s'entendre si tu m'avais
parlé vous le 2 ans tu m'aurais dit que
dans deux ans jallet remplir ou le
répéter tout arrive le suivi des
affaires en ce moment que je pensais
vivre dans dix quinze vingt ans que je
t'ai bien avec soi parce que la manière
de m'y rendre
c'est ce qui me rend mon envie qu'on
prend c'est le build up de la vie au
quotidien les gens c'est là que je
trouve mon jardin de jean de bonheur lh2
pour vrai et et remettons après vous le
ferez partie logis rien prévu j'aime les
aliments rien prévu puis même quand on
ne t'en décembre qu'on a annoncé wilfrid
pelletier
puis ma gérante à me dire ok
wilfrid va être en juillet puis jean fau
le bouter maintenant parce que je
comprends cdc des besoins de production
c'est gros c'est un festival mais j'en
étais comme mais qui j'ai toujours mon
gant nebout québécois dans mon agenda 8
moureaux gens comme moi ça me rend pas
dans la tête mais là c'est très laid et
du lot jean lassalle rocher ouais là
pour ça je comprends que jean le monde
notre grosse investi 80 de même parce
que j'en citerai comme ok vous survivre
il faut le faire mais c'est pour ce que
c'est pas dans l'accomplissement que je
trouve le fun de faire ce que je fais
mais c'est plus dans le comment ses
rangs depuis dans le moment présent
beaucoup coûté
puis j'ai autant de fun à faire un show
pour vrai que j'ai fait le capitole vers
un mois c'est 1000 places 6 comme le
plus gros show que ce que je faisais le
cas présent c'est ce que ces footeux
dire que j'en mille personnes devant toi
puis l'énergique tu reçois ces phobies
mais honnêtement j'ai fait des choses
dans ma première petite tournée genre à
petite grenouille de trois rivières
devant 80 personnes puissent sur scène
le bonheur que j'avais de comptes
ministre harper d'avoir du fun avec le
monde qui est l aude tarn m enfin
compris ça va être la même affaire à
wilfrid pelletier
c'est sûr que le niveau d'adrénaline que
le niveau de stress avant pilotes comme
de au monde humain voyons c'est
différent le j'entends être plus plus
mais honnêtement une fois qu'elle
chopard pourrais je raconte la même
manière que je raconterai comme dit ci
avait 10 personnes mais attendrait
comment les accords sur martin matte sur
le sont pas cassés mais qui c'est moi
qui faisais la technique derrière martin
didier martin matte et dès que celui-ci
dans sa tournée condamné à l'excellence
a été tournée énorme le cd des
proportions démesurées le tipi un succès
aussi fulgurant
puis après ça a été les beaux malaise
qui a été aussi comme succès tour du sol
puis il parlait de sa dernière tournée
qui est fait depuis dix ans j'avais
besoin de faire de quoi de plus petit
parce que c'était too much
ouais comme une fois que tu atteins sus
c'est tout moi tu sais si c'est trop
c'est trop gros piqué ce qui est après
tout c'est tout le temps envie de
dégrossir ton truc c'est tout le temps
mais rien de plus gros lot mais c'est ça
mais je pense caisse
il faut que tu retrouves pourquoi tu le
fais exactement justement pittis pour ce
qu'il y en a pleins d'histoires le cas
tant de gens qui ont comme connu un
succès rapide puis je pense justement un
rachid badouri qui dure sur votre
podcast mais c'est sa thérapie de jeudi
je les rencontrais une couple de fois
répétée
j'étais allé voir son ocho justement
semaine passée puis t il compter il
parle beaucoup de ce justement que ça a
été comme plus interdite
honnêtement il ya de quoi perdre les
pédales peut être de quoi perdre la tête
parce que si c'est vraiment quelque
chose de vraiment quelque chose d'un peu
irrationnel t2
si le jeu le prendre au pied de la
lettre petit je me dis que le 18 juillet
il ya 3000 personnes
jean 3000 personnes qui ont décidé de
payer puis de se déplacer parce que j'en
reçois des messages en intégrant mieux
déjà acquis par john de l'ontario déjà
qui par différents jacky parts et 3000
personnes là ont fait une pause dans
leur vie ont dépensé de l'argent on fait
de la route s'en viennent s'asseoir pour
moi j'en pour m'écouter parlé pendant
une heure et demie
c'est juste ça c'est moins gros que les
succès qu'ils rachètent de véhicules tic
qui ont explosé en carrière mais pour
vrai 6 répondre si je t'ai pas terre à
terre si j'étais pas bien entouré si
j'avais pu s'en lamente alpiq gipsy je
faisais pas jean le travail que j'essaie
de faire son mois le plus possible au
quotidien t avec le jeu trouve ceux qui
se soucient très important pour vrai il
ya de quoi perdre là il ya de quoi
perdre la tête
c'est même pas des gros succès comme tu
parlais de martin matte pu tout le texte
je suis conscient 100% que cette
importante le temps garder garder cette
vision limpide eux d'essayer de te
rapporter tout le temps à pourquoi tu le
fais pierre c'est ce à quoi de plus
comme terre à terre où je lui reprochent
de quitter vraiment ouais ouais qui en
ce moment une des vraiment une des
meilleures façons de rester toi même
puis je pense que tu le fais très bien
c'est par les médias sociaux les médias
sociaux au lieu de 2,2 facile tu le
souhaites tu deviens complètement
quelqu'un paie pas ou ce que tu t'es
capable de rester soi-même au quotidien
du fun story sans fil de justo qui leur
piquent i qui coupent des poivrons l'axé
comme vous signer ensemble mais vous
somme toute c'est vraiment proche d'eux
de toi j'imagine en fait c zéro de mise
en scène dit comment est arrivé comme un
non mais je dois sais que tu prends
quand même ton ciel pour en parler
ses seules actions de brennus que ton
quotidien maintenant mais mais mais
c'est un outil que toi je trouve ça très
bien comment comment ça a commencé
maintenant l'utilisation des médias
sociaux pour toi ça a commencé au cégep
moi j'ai étudié en arts et technologie
des médias du cégep de jonquière qui
comme un groupe gamme sont pas réputés
comme les animateurs de radio et il
était même aux étudiants radio la bonne
enfant que j'ai étudié lopy comment ça
commence et le pauvre et elle le côté
genre et c'est comme story authentique
de comme pas si j'ai des enfants parce
que c'était pas de truc c'est pour faire
mr oui c'est comme très genre et sur le
flyer se prononcer le pic où je raconte
de quoi petit espace de quoi que je le
comté rapidement comment sa partie ok
parfait comment ça commence ça a été au
cégep gens sur ce match at dans le fond
je faisais des story genre sur cette
chatte racheter complètement saoul gens
des parties où ces jeunes gens rien de
mieux que tout le monde mon travail mais
c'était nécessaire pour vrai santé
souffre et qui se passait toutes les
affaires qui pourrait-il cégep de
jonquière ktm fait réputé que mardi
bourdillas téléphones les plus réputés
pour être saoul
ouais ça brasse fait qu'on trouverait ça
a commencé de même je faisais des
snapshots j'appréciais déjà précédé ce
match à ton père tu le sais tout un
genre est ce procès de quoi n'ont pas
vieilli
oui non c'est sur exactement qui fait
que tu es beaucoup sur les gens je
faisais ça pis le les légendes du cégep
mais comme tout le monde au cégep me
suivait et mettons pas ce que c'était
drôle l'historien mathieu quand il était
dans des parties faisant des affaires à
tanger police était pas tout un volet
décider qui des fois m
c'est ça que ça a commencé de même puis
après sa belle un enfant en arrivant à
montréal
si j'avais quand même un gros risque
excuse moi ce qu'il m'a juste pour
rester dans le contexte qu'est ce qui
est fait le mouvement après atm du fait
des stages dont on fait une vente des
stages de cinq semaines un genre nrj
puis rouge fm à montréal
puis c'est vrai qu'en arrivant à
montréal mais je continuais de faire des
snapshots mais l'artiste est détruite au
quotidien quand même quand je voyais de
quad drôle c'est là avec la tchatche
avec comme développer le réflexe de
hockey ce qui est drôle qu'est ce que
l'on trouve le forum c'était au temps
d'attenté des murs ou des situations
quotidien ou comme quand je voyais de
quoi de qui fait quoi
je les ai filmés ou jean faire un zoom
bon sens dans le métro où c'est à
beaucoup commencé d'être de réaliser 25
de réaliser un mariage en avait beaucoup
c'était beaucoup ce témoin ma vision de
montréal ces gens je faisais beaucoup
d'affaires comme ça accueilli comme de
bouche à oreille pour vrai les gens
s'abonner à moi sur ce match a de plus
en plus puis après ça pendant ma
première année de l'école de l'humour
j'ai été dans un top noir ces petits
genre où les 50 personnes à suivre au
québec sauf nam kia sur ce match ouais
mais tu danses à la pauvre est pour moi
ça a été gentil j'étais quand même un
peu flou regardez dans cet opus on
rappelle à l'école de l'humour j'ai
personnes me connais j'ai aucune
visibilité autre que les petits réseaux
sociaux puis dans ce top là c'est que du
monde connu maintenant c'est que je t'ai
andré guillaume lemay thivierge du genre
marilou trois fois par jour en mettant
comme au shit dans cette école maquis
puis ça ça m'a apporté vraiment une
grosse vague de gens qui ce soir abonnés
puis la première journée où je voyais
mes abonnés montée 64 fait voyez pas les
abonnés montée mais tu voyais le nombre
de view ce matin quand j'ai vu ça monte
ça a été j'ai stressé gens jetés comme
au kilo il ya plein d'hommes se sont
abonnés à moi parce que dans la
description ça faisait étudiant à
l'école nationale de l'humour c'est
story vous feront rire à tout coup jean
pierre domecq l'acheter comme a dit le
gérant je me dois d'être drôle je fasse
rire à toury ou à tous genres angoua et
c'est ce qui fait que j'ai commencé jean
la première journée où la 2e journée
quand j'ai eu sur boom d'abonnés là j'ai
commencé à essayer de payer des affaires
en main puis mes amis m'ont dit jean
t'es pas drôle
là j'ai eu un deux minutes au mont du
fait que j'ai comme arrêter de faire 10
story pendant deux trois jours parce que
j'étais stressé c'est qu'au moment du
genre qui le stress retombe et puis ma
vie nature et leur prix puis je me suis
remis en avant les réflexes naturels
d'avant celle là ça a déclenché puis que
j'ai eu jean le tout à partie puis le
chat comme changer leurs algorithmes âme
en effet que j'en sais un chien fait que
j'avais pu si jamais j'avais trois mille
view sur mr driss heureux sur ce match a
tranché dans le pays le jour au
lendemain j'en avais gens à 800 mhz et
en finale après ça le instagram comme
instaurer leur liste ristori mais là
c'est ça qui est drôle c'est que moi je
serais je voulais pas faire de ce
théoricien faye g parce que j'étais
comme finissant l'école l'humour pis je
me rappelle il ya des maisons mariano
madiop catherine levac qui me suivaient
sur instagram jeter comme elle je veux
pas mettre de quoi sur instagram parce
que j'ai ainsi voici l on peut trouver
ça drôle de me juger pour être surmonté
un king à ce moment là fait que je me
terrier blanc m'a dit je me souviens
m'être le plus drôle de snatch ap
je le mettais sur instagram et et une
soeur 8 sur 10 et là aussi un petit
baume le lait views était quand même bon
le tilt ratio était bon trait saillant
fait que jeter comme au shit et la tata
tata de fil en aiguille j'ai comblé
matran transposer sur instagram je
m'intéressais n'importe qui qui allait
voir ce pilote ça a été vraiment comme
l'album no 2 comme fou si je dois à un
béton en janvier l'année passée j'étais
à 4000 abonnés sur un tailleur peut-il
l'achalandage à 58 mais le mettons ça a
vraiment été puis j'ai jamais rien fait
de sponsoriser j'ai jamais vendu mes
réseaux
j'ai jamais comme dit follow me sens
vraiment comme était un jean degros
bouche à oreille les fans de partage de
6% qc ca
comme de baume cinq ans puis content
d'être passé par le genre de transition
snapshot puis le genre de petit bout
menant city parce que si tu jour au
lendemain aujourd'hui mais ton jeu mais
très rarement ses agents soixante mille
abonnés 500 grammes sans avoir comme
relais en question c'est quoi ce que je
fais sur instagram
je pense que j'aurais pu justement
devenir cette personnalité cc c'est
dangereux puis moi papa de l'humour mais
d'une autre façon je l' ai vécu un peu
avec avec mon corps d'instagram c'est de
sortir de l'état d'avoir d'avoir tout
repos loin le plan d'affaires qui n'ont
le faut que je prenne les meilleures
photos passé il faut que ce soit des
photos profils aussi la photo a pas de
likes et kaman en faute puisqu'il y en a
mais c'est ma soeur qui m'a dit que tu
fais ce genre 6 euros tout à faire ce
que j'ai fait
effectivement dis-moi g20 moi faire ce
geste est souvent en exemple justement
comme les candidats d'audi parce que tu
es comme plusieurs amis qui ont fêté au
dépit quand les gens me demandent
souvent comment tu fais pour gérer des
réseaux sociaux de la blache comme un
c'est tellement rien et que c'est
tellement venu numérique n'en profite
moi j'ai vu l'étape de gérer mon
installé en mcad mille abonnés j'ai vu
la comprends mais je vais tout monter
graduellement puis jean toute ma gestion
de taux et comme très très très naturel
mais je nomme souvent sortir du jour au
lendemain de genre 5000 abonnés puis
d'avoir mettons 170 ça me crée l
angoisse mais j'en serais pas mais sont
appris à le faire tranquillement
c'est comme dans une rue pelée réflexe
de qui possédait pas drôle ce n'est pas
ses mots c'est pas moi c'est comme
toujours la main gauche j'attache si
vraiment ce qu'ils continuent à
entretenir ce site du monde qui faisait
déjà avant wayne odesnik avec un 12 mai
l'abonné fait que la différence entre 12
mirent à 150000 est énorme et pas
vraiment dire et déjà comme tribune si
j'ai usé c'est la même chose de même
contenu essentiellement ces photos des
photos de photoshoot belle
ouais ça finit le nom mais si ça peut
vraiment pas mon théâtre jaurès à se
remettre
c'est paralysé ses paralysant quand on
commence à réaliser en plus en plus et
attribue un certain succès à la
réception de ce que tu fais fait que
l'offre si les vues sont pas bonnes mais
là c'est à dire c'est ce qu'ont les
succès des avoirs qui lève pas fin
octobre le gartner pense à ceux puis
quand tu fais le switch de faire prendre
comme quoi toi tu as fait 41 8 on dit et
pas drôles de femmes qui faute d'argent
je vois avec moi by chris taub heim
l'espace y est et est allé tellement une
grosse pression plus loin de gros est
témoin j'ai tout le temps ne change pas
obligé de faire des story de ces jeux
j'en fais parce que pour rester c'est
naturel c'est un réflexe du genre j'aime
seul faire puisque je mets ça me fais
pas chier à le faire sans ces prêts
j'aime ça ça me fait rire pour vrai
puisque je me sens très pauvre et et je
réécoute des affaires des fois je crois
que ça me plairait gens j'ai ri de bon
coeur des fois des trucs que j'ai mis à
la fin j'ai zoomé et et puis des fois je
dois être dans deux jours le terme est
tombé c'est rare quand même parce que
pourrait justement dans un réflexe je
vois beaucoup d'affaires de rôle puis si
ça vient naturellement
mais des fois je vois maintenant mon
compte qui est une journée ou deux cents
story s'est jamais rien pendant deux
jours puis pendant ces deux journées
l'homme et je dirais avec massa puis son
bébé genre et on veut faire des
commissions vont marcher en se promenant
on fait des trucs que je suis jamais des
apajh écoute des faits george les
délivre tpiy ça c'est la base c'est la
fin la plus importante il faut tellement
qu'il garde son équilibre genre près de
toi pour pouvoir aller dans les sphères
qui sont vraiment débile puis un peu
genre justement comme à l'opposé de ces
humains ville dignité des grosses phases
de succès au micro affaires de justement
des chaudes et hilde f t après wilfrid
pelletier
je sais que je vais avoir le goût
d'aller faire des shows genre est de 20
comme ça en france j'en ai plein de
petits chocs h et i konpran après
wilfrid lebon fond de ma tante est notée
pour pas tout le temps aussi quel monde
attendre
what's next quoi la plus grosse affaire
c'est qu'on a piloté le monde à qui il
ravit wilfried fayt le monde n'ayant
qu'il va faire quoi le sens berck à des
kilomètres sans ben ça marche pas parce
que dans deux mois et accueille a échoué
dans un film on est tellement gentille
un rapace
le monde ce qu'on va retenir ça va côté
du barca secteur c'est le monde est
tellement dégradée
je le dis même pas tu sais même pas le
monde et rien ne viendra pas c'est juste
une vieille rapaces dira pas mais pour
fmi j'adore beaucoup ses traits sa
grande place way rapaces des sequalum
aussi beaucoup les charognards
tilera pas charles devoe tout le monde
niveau d'eau m'est témoin je suis
rapaces aussi il ya deux types de
rapaces il ya les rapaces positive et
les rapaces négatif son bail à finaliser
mettez moi je me rappelle aussi dans la
ville j'ai je ne fera pas son envie si
j'aime ça comme fallait un petit nid
cuniculus en face une bonne rapaces
j'aime sa rentrée dans les événements
des fois j'ai prié sera pas cependant à
vie mais une bonne rapaces
pas besoin d'aller mauvaise rapaces
celui qui justement vos comme
s'approcher du monde qui ont du succès
de m
ils peuvent créer jean modérateur de
même là j'ai vu venir de loin jeunesse
mon radar rapaces mais puis-je encore
troy davis comme ce à partir du lever du
lit et ce avec un succès comme seul taux
plein de nouveaux amis qui veulent ce
qu'ils veulent a gelé pas en fait c'est
que je l' ai pas vécu par rapport à
miramas faire aimer ton amitié social se
lancent à ce que je pour régis danville
of hip hop j'ai beaucoup d'amis mais mes
amis j'ai changé c'est qu'il faudra bien
ça ça me stresse pas de je vais avoir un
succès si les véhicules genre je le vis
depuis une couple d'années le teddy bear
en connaissant s'éloigner secondaire le
terrain dans mes billets monter comme si
on s'est vus hier lorsqu'un mais j'en
sors je le vis beaucoup je le vis
beaucoup mais tant par rapport à la
sphère professionnelle
ce titre running high avec ma gérante
avec mon équipe c'est beaucoup de tirs
le camp sortie d'école de l'humour pipi
genre que personne comprenez ce que je
faisais et puis j'avais pas la
validation du public j'avais porté des
affaires comme ça il ya plein de monde
qui me regardait le jean qui mettait
comme et ne soit épais de la main un
stylo jean ciao bye le gentil rien il
comprend puisque là
moi j'ai pas changé lâchant même
personne en sortant de l'école je fais
la même affaire que je faisais à l'école
note aiguë mais là quand ils voient que
j'ai en même temps j'ai su que c'était
le genre soit des offres est tous bords
tous côtés puis quand je vois les offres
qui sont vraies puis les gens avec qui
j'ai vraiment envie de travailler des
gens avec qui je peux faire confiance
puis je vois les offres aussi qu'ils
sont juste comme étant opportuniste de
comme mondiale envoyé à l'été jusqu'au
pissos james o faire la différence puis
la part des choses notre oui non c'est
pour ça que c'est cela qui est important
d'être bien entouré vie d'avoir une
équipe ça mais tant qu'ils connaissent
bien puisqu'ils ont de l'expérience
pierre qui ferait confiance pour pouvoir
justement des ti falala la nuance entre
c'est un allié ou jean vieira passe de
satin c'était dur de trouver quelqu'un
qui te faisais confiance que justement
maintenant mais je pense qu'un gérant
sirikit approche le way
ça c'est fait mais ça s'est fait comme
naturellement et la face que j'ai vu que
je m'identifiais pas vraiment comme un
humoriste prévu que je faisais mes
petites affaires tranquillement pas vite
avec mes amis puis que ça les bains
j'avais pas que j'avais besoin d'une
gérante ou si j'avais pas seulement
villa d'avoir une gérante tout de suite
tout en gérant puis à m'amener ben c'est
comme ça mais de fil en aiguille 7
rappelle marié ève je la connaissais été
atténuée nous donner une conférence à
man à l'école de l'humour je me rappelle
ce c est elle qui me l'a rappelé
sèchement rappelé paul j'ai dû 15 fois
le mot rappel l'an dernier en complément
des amis mais je vous rappelle que je me
rappelais que je me rappelais pas marié
va nous donner une conférence à l'école
a mené dans notre cours de gestion de
carrière il ya plein d'intervenants du
milieu qui ne nous parlait puis amman et
de nous voir bien nous parler des
méfaits du genre à parler d'un type sa
vision in après le court mois puis une
musique bons amis de l'école madeleine
on était allé voir marié ève dont il y
avait dit que nous donne espoir en ce
milieu logeant on dirait que tu y as
page idea passe quand j'avais 10 heures
j'avais dit à pau les dérapages de la
paf ça me donne espoir en ce milieu là
puis on dirait que tu me donnes genre as
this has peu de faire de quoi dedans
là-dedans j'avais dit ça mais ça on sera
même gentil ça fait trois ans maintenant
et je me rappelais pas d'avoir été voir
marié pour heather strong et puis après
ça mais logifem et deux petites tournées
mais première tournée pilotes ils m'ont
parlé beaucoup de monde dans le milieu
mais tout le monde est comme un matisse
pani barès and influence armatis pour
une marine en influençant puis marié va
s'est dit jean marie ève dans vie à la à
vos postes faire une idée de quelqu'un
par rapport à ce talent
perso je trouve cela remarquable chez
quelqu'un mes gars s'est dit si aux
alentours de lui en ce moment il doit
avoir quelque chose qu'on prend avec moi
je vais aller voir son chauffe et mariam
écrit effet comment je me revois ton
chauffe et j'ai donné des billets à un
nouveau le show puis là a vu ce qui se
passait quand geste sur sagna a vu pas
mal est fait qu un show mathilde four
puis à la capote et était commenté jean
leman on est quand même dans une
catégorie déjà ressenti mais la vue à
vue jean le japon a levé le potentiel
puis marié va être une personne très
humaine aussi mon mari mon étreinte si
je vous disais que je traîne dans le
subconscient qui j'aime ce livre d lire
des livres dessus la méditation sur ce
prêt colpi marie-eve est injuste dit
jean à mathieu il faut que j'avais
photos parlent danger goût d'aller
parler on va prendre un café fallait
prendre un café on s'est parlé puis moi
j'étais très en mode jambes j'étais très
laid back un peu sont mes gars de j'ai
pas le goût de me faire pogner justement
par une râpe à ce que de me faire
modeler dans un batteur de pas avoir de
mots à dire sur tiji capable de gérer
les affaires tuer les gens avant
d'embarquer avec quelqu'un je vais jouer
dessus sur la bonne personne et le
finalement ben c'est ça a été encore une
question de feeling puis de gens de la
vie en ligne version servent une couple
de fois que tu es comme un jeune fille à
femme tente on s'est rencontrés tac tac
tac ça défoule naturel gros coup de
coeur humain genre mariage la compta
comme une amie amy tu essaies soit avant
tout c'est pas genre dans le temps tim
gérance être élu manager de comme
moustapha gueye mutsch temps mais ça m'a
pas ce type jamais tu de ceux des
écoutes montrent moins pour devenir bis
n'ont pas de temps beaucoup le pensent
et le disent cette voile mais n'ont
jamais autant eu deux hommes étaient
gu10 j'ai été approché par des gens qui
attestait - faut que ça soit en effet
humain avant tout parce que j'aime mon
mari aime on se parle à ses quatre fois
par jour au téléphone on se on se parle
le soir à 10 ans des contextes gens on
ne dit si c'est une relation qui est
très très très genre intense avec j'ai
juste vraiment et avec le côté humain
avant tout que marié vraiment
l'expérience metelo a fait ça depuis
longtemps fait que c'est une question de
feeling nous embarque avec marielle puis
sa mère décision j'ai vraiment hâte à
joe cool c'est que les affalé permettant
que j'ai extrêmement avide halle aux
toiles être le moyen d'y aller sans et
sa magie pour commence la discussion
vraie fausse crise merci
3 2 1 c'est reparti il doit arriver les
encadrements fucked up dance all thy
d'at t il doit de faire plus que juste
toi qui parle d'un stage georges épouse
monte qui monte tout doucement qui ont
fait un jeu où on fait la vague jusqu'au
bout portant mais quand oui quand même
comme j'aime ça j'aime cependant les
shows si j'ai une bulle qui me passent
aux gens s'ils arrivent de quoi déjà en
bande et là dessus puis de partir ça
m'est déjà arrivé maintenant par le show
de jean faire faire aux gens de
vidéoclips de la tournée we will rock
you le gentil le monde tape peut-il donc
le seul je ne sais pas pourquoi ça mes
pensées je sais pas pourquoi c'est
arrivé mais j'étais comme lg à
disposition jean 500 personnes seule sa
sonnerie en institution technogym
d'argent fiché comme celle ce serait bon
de faire ça mais je sais pas comment
s'est rendu là comment ils l'ont fait
jamais ça c'est arrivé mais je l'aï
confirmé son bon faire germer sur un
serial buteur métier le monde capoter
d'avoir vécu seul intervenants ont tenté
plus qui me ferait aussi c'est que quand
je mets des avoirs de même sur l'état
gamme je parle des fois j'ai une petite
pensée pour ces gens qui comprennent pas
ce que je fais parce qu'il n'ya pas une
classe à part
ils sont encore en mon dieu c'est chaud
dans les camps de vacances si j'avais
fait rien c'est pas du mode fait il fait
danser le monde mais oui mais ça
m'arrive de partir sur déchire demain on
fait des anecdotes qui se transpose
c'est maintenant au capitole de québec
est arrivé avec les jets comme un
running gag les bottes à talons au genre
sur instagram le sait comme des grands
bottes j'en reçois deux autres qu'ils
avaient mis à m'amener au gras costumier
puis c'est la story qui a été pionnier
du genre mais je comprends pas pourquoi
c'est des fois que pour expliquer
pourquoi sapin autant quelque chose puis
expliquer ce qui met des débats de 1,9
mais c'est débile pour de vrai mais j'ai
mis ses bottes l'ops georges marchais
vers la caméra pigeard dit je suis le
grand monsieur sexy george et c'est tout
ce que j'ai dit c'est son enfant métis
et des talons en bois de montréal
j'ai mis ça mais j'en la story où tu
gens déjà en 2000 partageant le monde
ont viré foot et bachelot tout le monde
par le textile
dans le gers un bm d'un comme quelqu'un
qui m'a dit plugin des maîtres capitale
puis - david papaux game gens c'était
dangereux des pouilles mais avec moi
c'est finalement j'ai dit ouais fait que
sa montée au capital
après l'entracte est arrivé avec les
bottes j'en mettais tout croche j'ai
failli tomber sa bande qui avait jugé
entendu parler de ces bouquets jallet
accusé avant de monter sur scène
jeter comme ce que j'aime sommes
présentés - coulisses le g10 à manger
dans ce code pour tous ceux qui savent
pas c'est quoi l'anecdote des bottes
grand monsieur sexistes allait vivre un
moment de malaise dans trop de ces
partis j'arrive avec les boîtes métier
je dois j'ai fait un come de 15 minutes
avec ses bottes heures à parler tout
seul c'était super drôle dit c'est ça
qui crée un moment unique en fait est
que je vaux parfois non seulement parce
que j'étais comme ça mais après j'ai
décalé y était vieille acheté au moment
des faits c'est sérieux ben non en fait
c'est le grain costumier qui comme comme
il ou décoratifs série américaine autre
côté je connais bien la vérité générale
puis bref je vois tout le temps m'amuser
un grand costume permet d'alléger en
virée foot jeunes enfants et je tapote
puis à mes parents c'est d'informer les
boîtes étaient vraiment vieille fée qui
ont brisé jaillon tous des cons crise et
technologique mais ça s'aggrave genre
hip les bottes de gamme so sexy le monde
capoté mais le juste pour rire en ont
acheté une paire sa vie on a le temps
c'est parce que le monde m'appelle
demain jusqu'au mont du géant drik
c'est comme un enfant ayant tanjug que
tu veux pas qu'ils répètent le genre en
public c'est maintenant non
mais tant que le vent qui écoutait les
podcasts ils veulent plus de toi l'année
qui est pas tourné donné que tout plus
de show qui sont pas sots date cette
année qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'ils font
ils prouveraient ils vont voir mon
instagram c'est vraiment seul l'instant
c'est là que qui peut me comme consommer
au quotidien puis c'est là que tout les
consommer au quotidien mais c'est
vraiment son assaillant pour c'est là
que tout part les années groupe ardo
delà je m connu là dessus c'est la
caisse comme le plus actif puis c'est là
que tout découle en fait ces annonces
mais chose rsa gamme célébrant sa gamme
que mes cheveux sont mais je me sens
donc c'est ça qui est drôle d'une
nouveauté aussi c'est que j'ai une
colombe comme animal de compagnie que
j'ai achetés sur kijiji quand ces
compléments pour 50 50
puis la cinquantaine colombes en plus à
sa paire ruby du nom était baby g freche
trajet donné son nom puis dans le fond
j'avais fait un terme à rubis un peu
pour la joke c'est une colombe et un
infâme chance ça me faisait rire puis
l'a finalement mais c'est rendu que je
m'occupe du conquérant devant 6000
abonnés sa part rapport puis je me sens
jusqu'à moi mais je me sers du comte de
ruby pour annoncer des trucs en primeur
au québec c'est comme j'ai reçu une
lettre mon dan fan-club plus d'enfants
est loin d'avoir les quatre choses
soldats temps genre quatre heures en
avril ça a été annoncé sur connerie by
sap a été annoncée hier dans son les
gens c'est qu'ils sont fans plus minces
à bon-encontre ruby fait que des
primaires là dessus puis aussi d'être
vidéoclip de rugby cela même si aucune
collonges et donc 122 oui c'est gros
comme un tel survolé à la partie belge
est en cage mais jalibert coelho
dalphond bien reçu we have all have all
the grove qui craint qu'à la théorie a
fait un gros tiers c'est ce week end
je peux vous faire entendre passera dans
le jeu pas vraiment je peux vous faire
attendre
à chaque fois la théorie a fait ce bruit
le ses joueurs sapin
m oui je l'admets signer la passe oui
oui oui elle est possédée par la terry
wey canada première fois qu'elle me fait
ça j'ai failli sortir ça commence comme
un beauf france a fini en janvier
sociable mais vraiment ça surprend
j'aurais vraiment bien doté le jeu la
portée parce que c'est drôle est allé au
show de collaborateurs pour le sucre
puis dans la répète l'après midi mon
fils julien on parle au peuple
julie à la presse une colombe et comme
toute la porte en soi je la veux j'ai vu
simon shaw apporte la semaine ok pas
fait j'apporterai be le pendant à poster
géant rubiales chier sur julie snyder
c'était comme mon ami mais après sa mort
marilyn joker on veut des jeux dans les
loges qui admettons qu'il ya quand même
grand lille âgée aujourd'hui l'île aux
pies âme et on a comme veille m siri
bien loin bien j'ai dit viens ici à me
reconnais donc à s'en vient c'est
intelligent de nouveau impressionnant
dire quelque chose de gigantesque y
avait peut-être choquer les zones asie
j'adore y beaucoup de différences entre
ubi puis un poulet n'a aucune marge
d'ebit depuis l'ong aucune aucune trace
mon analyse théorique je salue
d'ailleurs qu'une noix de compagnie
c'est débile j'ai une noix compagnie je
dis oui moi je dis noah mais j'ai pas de
doigts hockey est-ce que
c'est quoi qui t'attire à part la scène
toutefois d'autres enfants dans ta vie
où tout va dans ce sens à tous de faire
je te tiens je vais avoir un talk show à
la télé je vois je fasse la radio je
suis loin de tout est joué remboursant
oui je te fare lg comme pas si je vais
tout faire bien moi mettons tout sauf
acquis qui se jalousent ou pour un non
c'est ça c'est vraiment chacun puis ça
c'est une afrique maintenant vraiment
mais je peux pas parler mais pas
vraiment des projets s'il faut l'état
si on dit qu'on suit à colombes sur vous
tous de venir voir passer sur amendement
mais ouais c'est vraiment cool pourrait
il ya un genre un documentaire qui se
tourne en ce moment j'en sûr comme toute
l'ascension valfré pelti jambes c'est
cool c'est sur une belle plateforme puis
tout puis par une bonne équipe mais je
peux rien dire mais s'il faut l'extrême
et hong kong et c'est nouveau
qu'on disait
dans ce coin et le jeu pourrait
contraindre pomme étant bouchées tepa
isf
merci infiniment merci thème favori pour
rester vraiment très intéressant j'ai
adoré ça extrêmement une belle rencontre
grand prix